L’être humain possède cette merveilleuse adaptation
qui lui permet de simuler mentalement
ce qu’il projette faire dans la vie réelle.
C'est une prouesse qu'aucun de nos ancêtres ne pouvait accomplir
et qu'aucun autre animal ne fait aussi bien que nous. C'est une adapation extraordinaire.
Tout comme la préhension, se déplacer sur deux jambes et le langage,
c’est l’une des choses qui a fait descendre notre espèce de l’arbre
pour la conduire au centre commercial.
Et....(rire)---nous l’avons tous fait.
Bien sûr,
Ben & Jerry's n'a pas de glace au foie et à l'oignon.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'ils en ont testé et fait «Beurk!».
C'est parce que sans quitter son fauteuil,
on peut simuler cette saveur et faire «Beurk!».
Voyons comment fonctionnent nos simulateurs d'expériences.
Faisons un diagnostique rapide avant de poursuivre.
Je vous invite maintenant à envisager deux versions du futur.
Essayez de les simuler et dites-moi laquelle vous préféreriez.
L'une est de gagner à la loto. Disons, 314 millions de dollars.
Et l'autre est de devenir paraplégique.
Pensez-y un moment.
Vous ne croyez probablement pas avoir à y réfléchir longuement.
Chose intéressante, il existe des données sur ces deux groupes de gens
qui illustrent leur niveau de bonheur.
Voici ce à quoi vous vous attendez, non?
Mais ça, ce ne sont pas les données. Je les ai fabriquées!
Voici les données réelles. Vous avez échoué le test et vous n'en êtes qu'au début du cours.
Parce qu'il s’avère qu'un an après avoir perdu l'usage de leurs jambes,
ou avoir gagné la loto, les gagnants de loteries et les paraplégiques
sont aussi heureux les uns que les autres.
Ne vous en faites pas trop d'avoir échoué le premier test,
parce qu’ invariablement tout le monde échoue ces tests.
Les recherches effectuées par mon laboratoire
et par les économistes et les psychologues du pays
dévoilent quelque chose d’assez étonnant.
Il s’agit du biais de l'impact,
c'est à dire, la tendance à disjoncter du simulateur
qui tend à nous faire croire que la différence entre les résultats
est plus significative qu’elle ne l’est en réalité.
Les enquêtes sur le terrain et en laboratoire
démontrent que le fait de gagner ou perdre une élection, conquérir ou perdre un amoureux,
obtenir une promotion ou non, réussir ou échouer un examen à l'université
etc., a moins d'impact, est moins intense et plus éphémère
que les gens ne s’y attendent.
Une étude récente et très étonnante
concernant l’impact de graves traumatismes de vie
suggère que ce nous avons vécu il y a plus de trois mois,
à peu d’ exceptions près,
n’a aucun impact sur notre bonheur.
Pourquoi?
Parce que le bonheur peut être fabriqué.
Sir Thomas Brown écrivait en 1642, «Je suis l'homme le plus heureux du monde.
J'ai en moi ce qui peut transformer la pauvreté en richesse, l'adversité en prospérité.
Je suis encore plus invulnérable qu'Achille; je suis à l’abri du destin. »
Quelle sorte d'engin remarquable cet homme a-t-il donc dans la tête?
Il s'avère que c'est exactement le même engin que nous possédons tous.
Les êtres humains sont dotés de ce qu'on pourrait appeler un système immunitaire psychologique.
Un système de processus cognitifs essentiellement inconscients
qui nous permet d’altérer notre vision du monde
de sorte à nous réconforter face aux situations que nous vivons.
Tout comme Sir Thomas, nous possédons cet engin.
mais nous ne semblons pas le réaliser.
Nous fabriquons le bonheur mais croyons que le bonheur est quelque chose que l’on trouve.
Nous connaissons tous des gens qui fabriquent leur bonheur.
Je vais tout de même vous présenter des données
et on n'a pas à chercher très loin.
j'ai cherché dans le New York Times des exemples de gens qui fabriquent leur bonheur.
En voici trois exemples:
«Je me sens tellement mieux physiquement, financièrement, émotivement, mentalement
et en presque tout autre aspect. » «Je n'ai aucun regret. »
«C'était une expérience glorieuse. » «Je crois que tout s'est terminé pour le mieux. »
Qui sont ces énergumènes qui sont si heureux?
Le premier est Jim Wright.
Les plus vieux se souviendront de lui: il était président de la Chambre des représentants et
il a démissionné dans la honte lorsqu’un jeune républicain nommé Newt Gingrich
a découvert qu'il avait fait une transaction louche.
Le démocrate le plus influent du pays
a tout perdu.
Il a perdu son argent, son pouvoir.
Qu'en dit-il des années plus tard?
« Je me porte tellement mieux physiquement, financièrement, mentalement
et en presque tout autre aspect.»
En quel autre aspect peut-on se porter mieux?
Végétal? Minéral? Animal? Tout semble bien avoir été adressé.
Vous ne connaissez pas Moreese Bickham.
Il a dit ces mots lorsqu'il a été libéré.
Il avait 78 ans et il avait passé 37 ans
dans une prison de la Louisiane pour un crime qu'il n'avait pas commis.
Il a finalement été innocenté à l'âge de 78 ans
suivant un test d’ADN.
Et qu'avait-il à dire de son expérience?
«Je n'ai aucun regret. C'était une expérience glorieuse. »
Glorieuse! Cet homme ne dit pas,
«Il y avait des gens sympas et une salle d'entraînement. »
C'est « glorieux »,
un terme que nous conférons généralement aux expériences religieuses.
Harry S. Langerman a proféré ces mots et son nom pourrait vous être familier
mais il ne l’est pas, parce qu'en 1949 il lit un article dans un journal
au sujet d'un kiosque d'hamburgers appartenant à deux frères dénommés McDonald.
Et il se dit « C'est vraiment une idée géniale! »
Il les rencontre. Ils lui disent
« Nous pouvons vous céder une franchise pour 3000 dollars. »
De retour à New York, Harry demande à son frère, un banquier en investissement,
de lui prêter les 3 000 dollars
et son frère de lui répondre
«Personne ne mange d’hamburgers.»
Il ne lui prêtera pas l'argent et six mois plus tard
Ray Croc eut la même idée.
Oui, les gens mangent des hamburgers,
et Ray Croc est devenu pour un temps l'homme le plus riche en Amérique.
Et puis finalement,
certains d'entre vous reconnaitrez cette photo d’un jeune Pete Best,
qui fut le premier batteur des Beatles,
jusqu'à ce qu'ils l’évincent
et engagent Ringo pendant une tournée.
Lors d'une entrevue en 1994, Pete Best
--oui, il est encore batteur et musicien de studio—
dit: «Je suis plus heureux que je ne l'aurais été avec les Beatles. »
Ces gens ont quelque chose d'important à nous apprendre:
le secret du bonheur.
Le voilà enfin révélé.
Premièrement: accumulez richesse, pouvoir et prestige
et ensuite perdez-les. (Rire)
Deuxièmement: passez le plus clair de votre vie en prison.
(Rire). Troisièmement: rendez quelqu'un très, très riche. (Rire)
Et finalement: surtout, ne devenez jamais membre des Beatles. (Rire)
«Mouais » Parce que lorsque
les gens fabriquent leur bonheur, comme semblent l'avoir fait ces messieurs,
nous leur sourions, incrédules, en nous disant:
«Mouais, au fond, tu ne voulais pas vraiment ce boulot. »
«Mouais, au fond, tu n'avais pas
tant en commun avec elle
et tu l’as réalisé précisément au moment
où elle t'a balancé sa bague de fiançailles à la figure.»
Sceptiques, nous croyons que le bonheur fabriqué
n'est pas de la même qualité que le bonheur dit «naturel» .
Que signifient ces termes?
Quand nous obtenons ce que nous voulons, on parle de bonheur naturel,
sans quoi on parle de bonheur fabriqué.
Et dans notre société, nous croyons fortement
que le bonheur fabriqué est de moindre qualité.
D’où vient cette croyance?
C'est très simple. Quel type de moteur économique
arriverait à tourner
si nous croyions qu’avec ou sans ce que l’on veut nous serions également heureux?
Toutes mes excuses auprès de mon ami Matthieu Ricard,
mais un centre commercial bondé de moines Zen
ne serait pas particulièrement rentable
puisqu' ils ne désirent pas grand-chose.
Je veux vous faire réaliser que le bonheur synthétique
est tout aussi authentique et durable
que le bonheur sur lequel on tombe
lorsqu’on obtient exactement ce qu'on visait.
En tant qu’homme de science, je serai direct
en vous faisant part de quelques données.
Voici un modèle expérimental utilisé
pour démontrer la fabrication du bonheur
chez le commun des mortels.
Depuis 50 ans, on utilise «le paradigme du libre choix»
C'est très simple.
On apporte, disons, six objets,
et on demande au sujet de les placer en ordre inverse de préférence.
Dans l’exemple auquel je fais référence, il s'agit
de reproductions de Monet.
On lui demande donc de classer ces reproductions
en ordre inverse de préférence.
Et on lui offre le choix suivant:
« Nous avons des reproductions en surplus.
Nous allons vous en offrir une
Vous devez choisir entre la troisième et la quatrième. »
Ce choix est un peu difficile
car l'une n'est pas beaucoup plus prisée que l'autre,
mais les gens choisiront plutôt la troisième
puisqu'ils la préfèrent légèrement à la quatrième.
De 15 minutes à 15 jours plus tard,
les mêmes stimuli sont présentés au sujet
et on lui demande de les classer de nouveau.
«Comment les classeriez-vous maintenant? »
Et que se produit-il alors?
Ce résultat s’est répété à maintes reprises:
Observez la fabrication du bonheur.
C'est ça le bonheur!
«Celui que j'ai est mieux que je ne le croyais!
Celui que je n'ai pas eu est moche! »
(Rire) Ça, c'est la fabrication du bonheur.
Quelle est votre réaction à cela? «Mouais?»
Alors voici l'expérience que nous avons faite
et j'espère qu’elle vous convaincra que
«Mouais» est erroné.
Nous avons fait cette expérience avec un groupe de patients
hospitalisés qui souffrent d'amnésie antérograde.
La plupart souffrent du syndrome de Korsakoff,
une psychopolynévrite. Suite à une consummation excessive d’alcool,
ils n'ont plus de mémoire à court terme.
Ils se rappellent leur enfance, mais si vous vous présentez à eux
et quittez ensuite la pièce,
ils ne vous reconnaîtront pas à votre retour.
Nous avons apporté nos Monet à l'hôpital
et avons demandé à ces patients de les classer
par ordre inverse de préférence.
Nous leurs avons ensuite donné le choix entre la troisième et la quatrième.
Comme tous les autres, ils ont dit:
«Merci docteur! C'est génial! J'avais besoin d'un nouveau tableau.
Je prendrai le troisième.»
Nous leur avons expliqué que nous le leur ferions parvenir.
Nous avons ramassé notre matériel, nous sommes sortis
et avons attendu une demi-heure.
De retour à la chambre : « Bonjour, nous revoici. »
Les patients nous répondent : «Désolé docteur,
j'ai un problème de mémoire, c'est pourquoi je suis ici.
Si je vous ai déjà rencontré, je ne m'en souviens pas.»
«Vraiment, Jim, tu ne t'en souviens pas? J'étais ici plus tôt avec les Monet? »
«Désolé docteur, je n'en ai aucun souvenir.»
"Pas de soucis, Jim. J’aimerais simplement que tu classes
ces reproductions par ordre inverse de préférence.»
Que font alors les patients? Assurons-nous d'abord
qu'ils soient réellement amnésiques. Nous demandons
à ces patients de nous dire laquelle
ils avaient choisie au départ.
Résultat: les amnésiques répondent au hasard.
Voici un groupe contrôle normal qui, comme vous,
identifierait aisément la reproduction choisie.
Mais dans le cas des amnésiques,
ils n'en ont aucune idée. Ils n’arrivent pas à repérer leur reproduction.
Voici ce que font les gens du groupe contrôle normal: ils fabriquent leur bonheur.
Vous voyez? Ils modifient leur préférence
d’une fois à l’autre.
Ces sujets démontrent
--c'est la magie que je vous montrais
et la voici ici sous forme graphique—
«Celle qui m'appartient est mieux que je ne le croyais. L'autre
n'est pas aussi bien que je le croyais. »
Les amnésiques font précisément de même. Que nous indiquent ces résultats?
Ils préfèrent celle qui leur appartient,
bien qu'ils ignorent la posséder.
« Mouais » est erroné!
Pour fabriquer leur bonheur, ces gens
ont profondément changé
leur réaction affective, hédoniste et esthétique envers cette reproduction.
Non pas parce qu'elle leur appartient,
puisqu'ils l’ignorent.
Les graphiques des psychologues
illustrent la réaction type des individus.
Pourtant, nous avons tous ce système immunitaire psychologique,
cette faculté de fabriquer le bonheur,
mais certains d'entre nous le faisons mieux que d'autres.
Aussi, certaines situations s'y prêtent mieux
que d'autres.
Il s'avère que la liberté
--l’aptitude à se faire une opinion et de changer d'avis—
est l'alliée naturelle du bonheur, puisqu’elle nous permet de choisir
l’avenir qui nous convient le mieux.
Mais la liberté de choisir
est l'ennemi du bonheur fabriqué.
Je vais vous démontrer pourquoi.
Dilbert le sait lui.
Le technicien dit: « Comment puis-je te malmener?»
« Mon imprimante rend une page blanche après chaque document. »
« Pourquoi te plains-tu d’avoir du papier gratuit? »
« Gratuit? Mais c’est mon papier, non? »
« Tu rigoles? Compare la qualité de ce papier gratuit
à celle de ton papier pourri!
Seul un fou ou un menteur prétendrait qu'ils se ressemblent! »
« Ah! Ma foi c’est vrai, Il semble un peu plus soyeux! »
« Que fais-tu? »
« J'aide les gens à accepter ce qu'ils ne peuvent changer. » Voilà.
Le système immunitaire psychologique fonctionne mieux
quand nous sommes complètement coincés.
C'est la différence entre une sortie et être marié, non?
Si vous sortez avec un homme
et qu'il se joue dans le nez; vous ne le reverrez plus.
Mais si vous êtes marié à quelqu’un qui se joue dans le nez,
on se dit qu’il a un coeur en or
et on laisse passer le reste. Non? (rire)
On trouve toujours le moyen d’être heureux.
Je vais vous démontrer que
ce que nous ignorons à notre sujet
peut éventuellement nous causer graves préjudices.
Nous avons fait une expérience à Harvard.
Nous avons créé un cours de photographie
et avons enseigné aux étudiants comment utiliser une chambre noire.
Nous leur avons remis des appareils photo, ils ont fait le tour du campus
et pris 12 clichés de leurs professeurs préférés, leur dortoir, leur chien
et autres souvenirs qu'ils voulaient conserver.
Ensuite, nous avons tiré une planche-contact
et ils ont choisi leurs deux photos favorites.
On a passé six heures à les développer avec eux
et ils les ont agrandies.
Ils ont deux superbes photos glacées grand format
de ce qui leur tient le plus à coeur et on leur demande:
« Laquelle comptes-tu nous redonner? »
« Je dois en redonner une? »
« Oui. Nous devons en garder une pour témoigner du projet scolaire.
Tu dois donc faire un choix.
Tu en gardes une et je garde l’autre. »
Cette expérience comporte 2 conditions.
Dans l'une, nous disons aux étudiants:
« Au cas où tu changerais d'avis, je garde l'autre quatre jours
mais ensuite je dois la faire parvenir au bureau chef.
Je serai heureux de"--(Rire)--ouais, «bureau chef»—
« Je serai heureux de te l'échanger. En fait,
je passerai à ton dortoir
--encore mieux, je vérifierai auprès de toi par mail.
Et si tu changes d'idée, il est tout à fait possible de l’échanger. »
À l'autre moitié des étudiants, on dit exactement l'inverse:
« Fais ton choix tout de suite car
nous devons l’envoyer en Angleterre sans délai.
Ta photo va s’envoler au dessus de l'Atlantique
et tu ne la reverras plus jamais. »
On demande à la moitié des sujets de chaque groupe
de prédire s’ils croient
qu’ils seront toujours heureux
du choix qu’ils ont fait.
L’autre moitié est simplement invitée à retourner au dortoir
et trois à six jours plus tard, nous leur demandons, à eux aussi,
s’ils sont toujours heureux du choix qu’ils ont fait.
Voyez ce que nous découvrons.
Tout d'abord, voici ce à quoi les étudiants s'attendent :
ils croient qu'éventuellement ils préfèreront la photo
qu’ils ont choisie à celle qu'ils ont cédée,
mais cette différence n’est pas statistiquement significative.
Elle est minime. Il importerait donc peu
qu’ils aient participé à l’une ou l’autre des conditions.
Non. Mauvais simulateurs. Voici plutôt ce qui se produit :
Que ce soit juste avant l'échange ou cinq jours plus tard,
ceux qui sont coincés avec leur photo,
qui n'ont pas le choix,
qui ne pourront jamais l'échanger, l'aiment beaucoup!
Alors que ceux qui tergiversent-- «Devrais-je l'échanger?
Ai-je choisi la bonne? Peut-être que non?
Peut-être ai-je cédé la bonne? »--agonisent.
Ils n'aiment pas leur photo. En effet,
même une fois la date butoir passée
ils ne l’aiment toujours pas. Pourquoi?
Parce que la condition réversible n’est pas propice
à la fabrication du bonheur.
Et voici la dernière étape de cette expérience.
On recrute un nouveau groupe d’étudiants à Harvard
et leur disons: « Nous offrons
deux cours de photographie
Dans l’un, vous aurez quatre jours pour choisir entre vos deux photos
et dans l’autre cours,
vous devez choisir sur-le-champ.
Quel cours préférez-vous joindre? »
Évidemment, 66% des étudiants, les deux tiers,
choisissent le cours où ils pourront changer d'idée.
Comment? 66 % des étudiants choisissent le cours dans lequel
ils sont voués à être profondément insatisfaits de leur photo.
Parce qu'ils ignorent les conditions indispensables à la fabrication du bonheur.
Shakespeare l'a bien dit et il confirme ma position
de manière emphatique:
« Rien n’est en soi bon ni mauvais; tout dépend de ce qu’on en pense. »
Jolie poésie, mais est-ce tout à fait vrai?
N'y a-t-il vraiment rien de bien ou de mal?
Une ablation de la vésicule équivaut-elle vraiment
à un voyage à Paris? Bien sûr que non.
La question peut-elle même se poser?
En prose plus pompeuse, mais plus près de la vérité,
Adam Smith, le père du capitalisme moderne, disait ceci
et cela mérite qu'on s'y arrête:
« La source ultime du malheur et des problèmes de la vie humaine
semble se trouver dans la surestimation de la différence
entre une situation permanente et une autre.
Certaines situations sont sans aucun doute préférables à d'autres,
mais aucune d’elles n’est digne d'être convoitée
avec cette avide ferveur qui nous mène à enfreindre
les conventions de la prudence ou de la justice, ou à corrompre notre quiétude d'esprit
par honte face à nos sottises du passé,
ou par remord face à l'horreur de notre propre injustice. »
En d'autres mots: oui, certaines choses valent mieux que d'autres.
Il est normal d’avoir des préférences pour un type d’avenir plutôt qu'un autre.
Mais lorsque ces préférences nous tiraillent trop fort et trop vite
et que nous surestimons la différence du résultat de nos choix,
nous sommes en danger.
Lorsque notre ambition est maitrisée, elle nous mène à la joie.
Lorsque notre ambition est débridée, elle nous pousse à mentir, tricher, voler, blesser les autres
et à sacrifier ce qui importe vraiment. Quand nos craintes sont contenues,
nous sommes prudents, circonspects, attentionnés.
Quand nos peurs sont débridées et amplifiées,
nous sommes irréfléchis et lâches.
La leçon que j’aimerais que vous tiriez de ces données
est que nos désirs et nos inquiétudes sont souvent démesurés
car nous possédons la faculté de fabriquer précisément le bonheur
que nous recherchons.
Merci.
(Appluadissements)